[Music]
on this saturday night
the indigenous communities overwhelming
grief
mourning the hundreds believed to be
buried at a former saskatchewan
residential school these are our kids
kids we never got to bring home
as fires consume two more catholic
churches in bc
the florida condo collapse why it was a
disaster
waiting to happen you kind of wondered
where did that water come from
and what's hampering search efforts
after keeping cove it out
australia's largest city locks down
[Music]
and mysteries in the sky there is only
one explanation
the pentagon's puzzling report on ufos
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us members of the kawasis first nation
in saskatchewan are paying tribute to
the hundreds of children
believed to be buried near a former
residential school
as many as 751 unmarked graves were
detected at the site
for people connected to the school and
the trauma inflicted in the residential
school system
the discovery isn't surprising but the
memories from this era have returned
and the wounds open again global
national's heather york's west is in
saskatchewan for us tonight
heather
it has been an incredibly emotional few
days for the families here on the
calluses first nation
and tonight the community is coming
together to formally honor the children
and others
found buried in a field near the site of
the former maryvale residential school
eagle club bunny tom didn't attend
residential school himself
but many members of his family did my
father attended maryville residential
school
my cook em my mushroom
my little sister also attended maryville
residential school
the trauma experienced by each person
was felt acutely throughout the family
a legacy of pain that has lasted long
after the school closed
the ones who attended residential school
brought it with them
throughout the rest of their life
they're still working on it and there's
in many cases they're still they're
still there to this day
it's why the discovery of so many
unmarked graves here
is so hard we definitely have relatives
buried there
the the tree the chief has already came
and talked to me
and and brought up names these are our
kids
kids we never got to bring home you know
the graves of those children now marked
by hundreds of small orange flags
in the days since the burial site
discoveries were announced community
members have gathered to honor those
that were lost
it's important to me to to
just do something in a way too to have
something to keep me busy
through my grief in regina prairie crowe
works on another tribute
the community activist is gathering 751
backpacks
each marked with an orange handprint she
plans to display at the saskatchewan
legislature
on canada day i think canada day this
year needs to be a
day of grieving a collective day of
mourning and grieving for the people of
the kawasis first nation the grief will
last
long after july 1st as they collectively
mourn
so many lives a moment of silence will
be held at 7
51 to honor the 751 people believed to
have been
buried here a number that will be added
to the 215 discovered in kamloops bc
and a number that will likely grow in
the weeks and months to come as more
searches
are carried out at other school sites
across the country
robin heather york's west near the cowas
first nation
in saskatchewan there is some support
for those who need it the indian
residential school survivors crisis line
is
confidential and available 24 hours a
day
the toll-free number is 1-866-925-4419
for the second time in less than a week
two catholic churches have been burned
to the ground in british columbia
both happened in the samilkamine region
in the province's southern interior
one of the fires happened around 3 a.m
in the community of headley southwest of
penticton
an hour later another fire burned in the
area of tropaca
near the canada u.s border the chief of
the lower samilcamine indian ban
tells global news he has little doubt
the fires are suspicious
of course it's suspicious two fires
again two more churches
and one night it's heartbreaking you
know we still have people who worship
and practice
their religion earlier this week two
other catholic churches on first nations
land in the okanagan burned to the
ground
those fires were deemed suspicious and
investigations are underway
global affairs canada confirms at least
four canadian citizens may have been
affected by the collapse of that condo
near miami
for privacy reasons it's not clear if
the canadians were killed or injured
but new details are emerging about the
building's structural problems
as jennifer johnson reports engineers
sounded the alarm
back in 2018. fire has spread deep
inside the rubble of the collapsed surf
side condominium building hampering
rescue efforts
as family members wait in agony to learn
the fate of their loved ones
rescuers are refusing to give up hope
all of our training tells us that for at
least
the first 72 hours there are high
likelihood
of people that could be alive in there
rescue teams are using
dogs cameras and listening devices and
bucket brigades in their search
it's a really really difficult time
right now you wake up in the morning
hoping that
that more and more people were pulled
out and
you know you know that just news hasn't
been what we had hoped
with no warning the 40 year old tower
collapsed early thursday morning
55 units came down as most residents
were sleeping
sergio lozano is looking for his parents
i was on the phone with her at 1 30. she
called me up
and she said i think there's an
earthquake and then the building started
to shake it rattled she
and she screamed and then the phone went
dead a structural survey in 2018 found
abundant cracking in concrete columns
beams and walls in the parking garage
residents of the building next door say
that garage was always flooded
you've noticed these things because
you'll come out in like a certain outfit
and it's a beautiful day and you go why
am i stepping in a puddle of water to
get them
to get to the car the towers builders
had to drive concrete pylons deep
into the sandbar but saltwater intrusion
can seep into concrete corroding the
steel inside
forensic inspectors will try to
determine what exactly led to this
building crumbling down
everyone wants to know what is the cause
we are going to conduct a full and
thorough investigation with all of our
local
state and federal resources coming on
the scene
a makeshift memorial with pictures of
the missing has been set up near the
site
for now it's a race against time for
rescuers
[Music]
and a gut-wrenching weight for loved
ones jennifer johnson
global news washington it's been a
constant race during this pandemic but
canada is showing signs of being in the
lead
over 76 percent of eligible canadians
have their first dose
and almost 30 percent are fully
vaccinated
and the feds have finally released
guidelines for double-dose canadians
including a coveted risk assessment tool
here's michaela couture
they are the sounds manitobans have been
waiting more than a month to hear
province started to trim restrictions
saturday allowing hair salons and
restaurants to reopen
with limited capacity takes a little
getting used to
even being indoors with all these people
again but
you know that's part of getting back to
normal in ontario hair salons are set to
open next week and the push is on
in toronto to ramp up immunization rates
sunday scotiabank arena will be turned
into one of the largest covid 19
vaccination
sites in canada where they expect to
hand out
25 000 shots in one day the focus has to
be on
the 25 percent or so of people who have
not even got a first dose let's think
about that
that's very worrisome for them the
number of fully vaccinated canadians is
climbing
even canada's top doctor got her second
dose saturday
and now many are asking once fully
vaccinated
what are they allowed to do the federal
government released guidelines friday
and relaunched this risk assessment
website in partnership
with the national institute on aging by
filling out the 21
questions about your potential gathering
canadians are supposed to get an idea
of how risky it could be but this
epidemiologist says
it's too complicated it already starts
on the first page
with a question that i was struggling to
understand even though i'm the
scientific director of ontario's code 19
science advisory table
and it's not valuable i'm sorry to say
the public health experts helped develop
the tool and while the creators
know it's not for everyone they say it
has already helped
tens of thousands of canadians this
really gives them
some expert guidance from some of the
leading experts across canada
to really help them make sense of what
they need to know as they start
navigating
you know gathering with others again
something more canadians are looking
forward to
as more provinces ease covet 19
restrictions
over the next week mike lacrouter global
news
ottawa millions of people in sydney
australia
are under a hard two-week lockdown
because of the spread of the delta
variant
just before the stay at home orders were
issued people lined up at grocery stores
to stock up
there are now close to 100 cases of the
delta variant the outbreak has been
linked to a limo driver
who wasn't vaccinated and tested
positive after taking an international
flight crew to a quarantine hotel
it's sydney's first lockdown since
december 2020
with low vaccination rates australia is
struggling to maintain its
early pandemic success british health
secretary matt
hancock is saying goodbye to his job
after being busted for an affair i've
been to see the prime minister to
resign as secretary of state for health
and social care
hancock had been facing calls to quit
since photos surfaced of his affair with
a senior aide
it wasn't the fact that he was married
but that he broke kova 19 rules
intimate contact between people from
separate households wasn't allowed at
the time
in his resignation letter hancock wrote
we owe it to people who have sacrificed
so much in this pandemic to be honest
would we have let them down
as i have done by breaching the guidance
we keep hearing there's a federal
election on the horizon in canada
speculation has long been simmering
canadians could be headed back to the
polls
ever since the liberals won a minority
government when the vote happens
it will be aaron o'toole's first
election squaring off against justin
trudeau
mercedes stephenson spoke with the
conservative leader and he sounds
confident mercedes
robin aaron o'toole has been the leader
of the official opposition
for exactly 10 months however despite a
series of scandals for the liberal
government
the conservatives are still trailing the
liberals in the polls
on this week's edition of the west block
i'll ask aaron o'toole
why he hasn't been able to capitalize on
liberal missteps
especially in key battlegrounds located
in ontario
and quebec o'toole insists he's
confident
and says when canadians look back at the
trudeau track record
they'll think twice before voting
liberal so the only poll that matters
mercedes
is election day i've been behind in
polls before
and have won because i'm experienced i
bring people together and i get things
done
and only the conservative party has a
plan mr trudeau competes with the block
the ndp and the green
uh to spend money to to shut down parts
of the economy
we need everyone working after kovit so
they'll have a stark choice
i also asked mr o'toole about
reconciliation with canada's indigenous
communities
last week in a speech the conservative
leader said the road to
reconciliation does not mean tearing
canada down
i asked him what that meant mr o'toole
says
it's about reconciling the horrific
parts of our past
with a commitment to do better i think
canada is a great country it is not
perfect
and when we celebrate it we need to
recommit to its principles that's what
i've said
mr trudeau and some of his ministers
almost want to cancel canada day
because we failed in the past let's
channel
that frustration of when we fall short
to make canada even better more
inclusive and to truly reconcile that
past that is at the center
piece of reconciliation reconciliation
the economic recovery
and the national vaccine rollout will
all likely be
key issues in any upcoming federal
election campaign
which it seems could be happening sooner
than many had hoped
perhaps this summer even given the
political climate here in ottawa
robin thanks for that mercedes and you
can watch the full interview with
opposition leader erin o'toole
tomorrow on the west block right here on
global coming up
one is the loneliest number now add a
pandemic to it
the perspective from an emergency doctor
in new mexico a hot air balloon has
crashed killing five
people police say the balloon hit a
power line and then caught fire
three men and two women between the ages
of 40 and 60 were killed
the pilot of the balloon is believed to
be among the dead
according to stats canada more than half
a million canadians over the age of 65
cope with feelings of isolation that
number was before the pandemic which has
only exacerbated the problem
limited contact with friends and loved
ones have taken a toll
and as jamie morocco reports loneliness
isn't just a state of mind
it can have serious even deadly effects
on the human body
since losing her husband in 2007
80-year-old sharon batala says her
day-to-day life has been lonely
and the pandemic has made it worse
social engagement was
down to practically zilch batalas says
loneliness has left her with feelings of
grief and sadness
for some those emotions can manifest
into physical ailments
loneliness actually has wide-ranging
consequences
for the entire body it affects the
immune system
it affects wound healing toronto
emergency room dr
jacques lee has seen this first hand
especially over the last 17 months
loneliness is as bad for you as smoking
cigarettes
in fact lee estimates loneliness kills
45 000 canadians each year
a staggering number he plans to target
with a new trial
beginning in september mount sinai
emergency room patients 70 years plus
who are diagnosed with loneliness
will be able to join a phone call
follow-up program
they work with the individual to
identify
goals that are meaningful to the
individual you know what would improve
their quality of life
volunteers will then coach patients to
reach those goals
a similar program has already found
success in australia
danilo bisdock has spent years studying
loneliness and says while the pandemic
has certainly
exacerbated isolation it's also offered
researchers a unique opportunity
to learn something new about
this capacity that makes humans human a
complex social interaction
back in calgary batala isn't convinced
there's a solution
there will always be loneliness the
human condition she says
and an unfortunate reality of aging
jamie morocco global news toronto
still ahead the odyssey continues for
the elephants
with a travel bug
a mammoth trek taking place in china has
intrigued wildlife
experts in march of 2020 a herd of
elephants left their nature reserve and
they've been on the go since
their slow sojourn has sparked
roadblocks towns and villages had to be
evacuated
and now these pachyderms are heading
home and that has fascinated scientists
even more here's reverend shannon
they are simultaneously lumbering and
majestic the 500 kilometer cross-country
tour of this herd of elephants
has captivated china their naps
their dips their highway strolls
all caught on camera authorities are
tracking
every plodding footstep
even evacuating neighborhoods in their
path the elephant's journey began in
spring of 2020 when they headed north
out of their nature reserve through
villages towns and eventually to the
outskirts of the huge provincial capital
kunming
in recent days they have started to head
south again
wow they just boomed like big news
becky shu chen is an elephant researcher
from kunming
she says these long treks are not
uncommon
but wild elephants in cities are we had
no experience with this ever in the past
the reason for their journey is still
unknown chen
says something may have frightened them
or they could have gained a taste
for the convenience of human grown food
the crops which are more tasty has more
nutrition and also they don't need to
spend like 18 hours
in the forest to looking for the blend
flavored food they can just stay in the
rice view there were made food
you should confuse asian elephant
numbers in china have
finally started climbing again in recent
years
now at about 300. we still want to have
more elephants
but how to help them to coexist with
local communities
especially to the new regions where
elephants
are going back the extensive drone
surveillance is helping researchers
learn more about the animal's behavior
i'm astounded that these these elephants
in china
are so calm around the drones and you
know they're asleep
in lying down they don't get up they
don't
have any reaction elephant expert
phyllis lee is
impressed with the efforts to keep the
animals and humans safe
but her great concern is that the gentle
but sometimes
deadly giants will struggle to find
somewhere to settle
never mind find their way home again
redmond shannon global news
tic london ufo up next the mysterious
object at the center of a u.s military
report
for years ufo enthusiasts have waited
for the day the u.s military opened its
files on possible alien sightings
while a much anticipated report on these
close encounters was finally presented
to america's congress
but as mike delay reports the chances of
finding any solid answers in its pages
remain a mystery
in 2004 the u.s navy saw something on
radar it couldn't explain
one of the planes sent to investigate
was flown by lieutenant commander alex
dietrich
who saw something unexplainable we were
able to
then visually pick up what we
described as a tic tac because that's
what it looked like this
white oblong shaped
object that was moving very fast
dietrich says she's not a ufo person but
she also can't unsee what she saw
and at least now the us intelligence
community is backing up her story
sort of a special report has been
delivered to congress
which details incidents involving the
u.s military encountering
uaps or unidentified aerial phenomena
which ufo researcher victor vigiani says
is their way of avoiding what he
considers
obvious these things are off-world
craft without a doubt the report doesn't
go
that far its major concern is
determining if there is a threat to u.s
national security
it concludes there's no one explanation
for all the incidents
although it does allow that advanced
technologies may have been used
beyond that or just beyond it doesn't
say
i have asked some of our senior
scientists and at least one of them has
stated that he holds the
extraterrestrial hypothesis
just above some of the others so if i
had to make a bet i would bet that it's
something off world but again
i don't have enough data oh my gosh that
this conversation is happening in such a
prominent way was once thought
impossible within the ufo community
considering the number of hoaxes
explainable phenomena credibility has
always proven to be
elusive it's a big step forward there's
no doubt about it's a big step forward
but it's not the complete answer
it's a truth but not the final truth
about what's out there
micro lake global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill
your canada tonight is a pair of ruddy
ducks in saskatoon
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you